es gibt diesen einen minister in berlin
da kann machen was er will es ist
irgendwie immer falsch praktisch jede
zeitung hat ihn schon abgeschrieben
warum andreas scheuer als
verkehrsminister ein totalausfall ist
mehrheit der bayern will neuers
verkehrsminister loswerden ein rücktritt
wäre das beste warum ist andreas scheuer
immer noch minister und auch hier bei
uns im zdf geht zu mindestens einen der
von neuer regelmäßig verlangt tritt
endlich zurück wegen der maut jetzt mal
ehrlich warum tritt ja nicht zurück gute
frage
was glaubt ihr denn warum macht ihr das
nicht ich bin christiane hübscher ich
bin korrespondentin hier im zdf
hauptstadtstudio und berichtet
regelmäßig über verkehrspolitik und wann
immer ich dass irgendwo erzähle werde
ich gefragt sag mal warum ist ja
eigentlich immer noch im amt
und das versuchen wir heute mal zu
klären ihr erinnert euch die maut oder
wie die csu sie ja so gerne genannt hat
die ausländer maut wurde hart gestoppt
im juni 2009 10 als der europäische
gerichtshof sagte könnt ihr nicht machen
ist diskriminierend gegenüber ausländern
und verstößt damit gegen eu-recht jetzt
dass es erstmal einen rückschlag
jetzt ist es schon auch enttäuscht das
war mehr als enttäuschend für andreas
scheuer denn zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte
er die verträge über das eintreiben der
maut längst unterschrieben mit zwei
betreiberfirmen die dann nach der
kündigung für den nun entgangenen
auftrag 560 millionen euro
schadensersatz fordern
560 millionen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen und zwar vom staat sprich von
uns ein das ist genau die summe die die
mautbetreiber in zwölf jahren laufzeit
verdient hätten
tja ihr sagt ihr wahrscheinlich das
reicht auch schon längst für ein
rücktritt wer unterschreibt den verträge
vor so einem wichtigen urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs noch dazu mit
so ner fetten schadensersatz klausel
aber was wenn der minister selber hier
sich sogar keiner schuld bewusst ist
schaut mal hier ich habe ihm das ganz
oft gefragt herr scheuer sie haben
gesagt auch in diesem haus
passieren fehler dann würde mich mal
interessieren wo genau konkret sehen die
fehler was würden sie heute in der
rückschau anders machen sie ganz
persönlich
er rutsche die franken waren natürlich
auch erwarten
weil ex post würde ich jetzt mal sagen
ja
jetzt wissen wir dass die
infrastrukturabgabe
mit der entscheidung des ogh so wie sie
formuliert wurde gescheitert ist kurzer
einschub nach dem bh weil er den erwähnt
hat das ist der bundesrechnungshof und
der hatte ihnen mehrfach schriftlich
gegeben das wasser mit den maut
verträgen vergaberecht verletzt habe
gegen haushaltsrecht verstoßen und die
schadensersatz regelung sei nicht
angemessen gewesen
aber hersteller welche firma wenn wir
jetzt im februar 2009 10 werden dann
würde ich auf die frage antworten haben
sie fehler gemacht bei der vergabe würde
ich mit nein antworten ja nichts falsch
gemacht da musste dann natürlich ein
untersuchungsausschuss hier
und der gilt ja gemeinhin als das
schärfste schwert des parlaments da
denkt man dann erstmal und jetzt wird es
richtig eng für den minister jetzt hat
er die entlassungsurkunde praktisch
schon in der hand sowie die
ausschussmitglieder damals zum sturm
geblasen haben wir müssten das dieser
untersuchungsausschuss kurz und
schmerzhaft arbeitet so dass wir am
schluss wissen was ist tatsächlich
passiert und wer trägt dafür für die art
verantwortung wir werden sehr genau
nachfragen warum wurde ein vertrag
unterschrieben den es so kein zweites
mal gibt in der bundesrepublik
deutschland die wahrheit ist so ein u
ausschuss ist ein ziemlich zahnloser
tiger
klar der kann erst mal alle akten zur
sache anfordern
heuer hat ja dann auch die ersten 50
ordner persönlich mit dem handwagen in
den bundestag gefahren
das sind die verträge zur pkw-maut
arbeit ist klar wir stehen bei allen
fragen zur pkw maut für maximal mögliche
transparenz mittlerweile sind das
zweieinhalb tausend ordner zur maut über
800.000 blatt papier
die die ausschussmitglieder jetzt eine
durcharbeiten müssen da ist erstmal ganz
viel belangloses dabei aber da wo es
dann wirklich wichtig wird da sind
plötzlich ganz große bereiche geschwärzt
und mehr als 20.000 seiten sind sowieso
schon alles
geheim eingestuft und gerade über die so
wichtigen geheimgespräche mit den
bietern
gibt es denn ganz zufälligerweise weder
vor noch nach bereiten die vermerke
behauptet jedenfalls das ministerium was
wollten sie nochmal herstellen herrscher
maximal mögliche transparenz die akten
die wir bekommen haben damals waren
entgegen der aussage des ministers eben
nicht vollständig und sie war noch nicht
umfassen aber immer mal wieder gibt es
auch erhellende momente da findet sich
zum beispiel diese e mail in den akten
der früheren leiterin des referats im
ministerium der wand die schon 2018 nach
zuschlagserteilung hat der entsprechende
bieter grundsätzlich einen anspruch auf
den entgangenen gewinn bei dem es sich
um einen dreistelligen millionenbetrag
handeln kann
tja und 560 millionen sind ein
dreistelliger millionenbetrag die 560
millionen werden wir nicht bezahlen nein
als ja auch bei solchen aussagen also
das wird nicht kommen
nein diesen ganzen denkwürdigen talkshow
auftritt den findet ihr übrigens noch
mal hier zum nachschauen aber noch mal
zurück zu den 560 millionen diese e-mail
der referatsleiterin die bedeutet ja im
ministerium wusste man schon ganz früh
lange vor vertragsabschluss was da an
schadensersatz drohen könnte aber die
große frage ist wusste dass auch andreas
scheuer persönlich und kann man ihm das
nachweisen oder lief das alles mehr so
auf staatssekretärsebene und der
minister selber war am ende gar nicht so
wirklich darüber informiert auch wenn er
natürlich die verträge unterschrieben
hat dann würde man am ende so eine art
organisationsversagen feststellen aber
eben nichts wofür man scheuer persönlich
verantwortlich machen könnte es werden
dann irgendwie alle und keiner gewesen
erneut können wir noch gar nichts
vorwerfen weil wir nicht wissen was er
von den dingen die wir hier raus
gefunden haben weiß oder wusste und was
eben nicht was man ihm vorenthalten hat
und im moment sagt herr scheuer ich
trage dafür keine verantwortung denn ich
wusste von nichts
und das müssen wir einfach klären ist es
tatsächlich so um aufzuklären darf der
untersuchungsausschuss natürlich auch
zeugen befragen
praktisch jeden aus dem ministerium der
mit der maus zu tun hatte jeder
referatsleiter aus dem kanzleramt der
dazu gange war
ehemalige verkehrsminister ehemalige csu
chefs das ist schon ein heißer stuhl
aber trotzdem darf man sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass da ein angeklagter sitzt
der machten geständnis und dann wird
irgendeine urteil gesprochen das geht
schon deshalb nicht weil es nämlich gar
kein angeklagten gibt wer eingeladen
wird kommt als zeuge und nicht als
angeklagte er ist zum erscheinen und zur
wahrheit verpflichtet aber mit der
wahrheit ist es ja immer so eine sache
man merkt natürlich dass eine ganze
reihe an zeugen entweder
erinnerungslücken haben oder verschieden
frage nicht beantworten wir wollen und
sich dann auch in widersprüche
verstrickt haben ist sehr mühsam
deswegen dauern solche zeugen fragen oft
auch bis zu 18 stunden die abgeordneten
versuchen dann durch penetrantes fragen
rauszukriegen gab es da wirklich gar
keine alarmglocken in diesem ministerium
kein risiko bewusst sein dass der ogh
die maut noch kippen könnte und was das
den steuerzahler kosten könnte
auf unsere frage hinaus ja wollten sie
das nicht wissen haben sie nicht mal die
frage gestellt was bedeutet dass dann
haben wir immer wieder antwort gekriegt
dafür bin ich nicht zuständig dafür
hatten wir die berater oder meinen das
hat keinen interessiert
es gab ja ein zeugen wer hat das bewusst
getan er hat gesagt ich ärgere mich
heute noch und schäme mich dass ich mich
an diesem projekt beteiligt habe und hat
die konsequenzen gezogen auch das
ministerium verlassen
es gab noch weitere kritische stimmen
aber die wurden alle beiseitegewischt
die würden nicht ernst genommen ja das
ist die halbzeitbilanz des u-ausschusses
ganz schön ernüchternd was andreas
scheuer selber wird dann erst als
letzter als dramaturgische höhepunkt vor
den ausschuss geladen und dann wird ein
abschlussbericht geschrieben aber dass
der ihnen dann wirklich noch zu fall
bringen wird das glaubt hier so richtig
niemand
denn über das schicksal dieses ministers
entscheiden in wirklichkeit ganz anderen
die bundeskanzlerin glaubt ihr
finde das an die scheuer eine sehr gute
arbeit macht aber selbst wenn angela
merkel das nicht finden würde hätte sie
gar keinen durchgriff aufnehmen sie kann
nämlich gar keinen minister feuerwehr
nicht ihre partei angehört das könnte
eigentlich nur er hier die vielleicht
wichtigste jobgarantie für andreas
scheuer ist immer noch der csu chef und
bayerische ministerpräsident markus
söder und der hält weiter die hand über
seinen parteifreund ein zentraler grund
ist sicherlich dass das geschäftsmodell
der csu immer noch trägt nämlich mit
bayrischen verkehrsministern viel geld
für bayerische infrastrukturvorhaben ins
land zu holen und das ist wahrscheinlich
auch die zentrale grund wo man sagt okay
aus bayerischer sicht macht er seinen
job gut und solange noch im bayerischen
bierzelt oder am stammtisch dafür
geschätzt wird ziemlich klar
anfang des jahres hat so der mal sehr
laut darüber nachgedacht das kabinett in
berlin zum sommer hin zu erneuern und
der war ganz klar auch andreas scheuer
mit gemeint aber nochmal zu andreas
scheuer kann man das einfach so
durchgehen lassen sie sind ja der
verantwortliche partei in der tat gibt
es fragen diese fragen müssen geklärt
werden und der untersuchungsausschuss
ist das edelste instrument des
parlaments also je möglichen fragen zu
klären und auch komplett auf zu arbeiten
ja da war schon ordentlich druck auf dem
kessel ein machtpolitisches spielchen
hätte eng werden können für andreas
scheuer
aber dann kam corona endlich hat keiner
mehr nach der markt gefragt stattdessen
konnte den großen krisenmanager geben
kümmerte sich als infrastrukturminister
persönlich um ein paar millionen
schutzmasken aus china natürlich für
bayern
die er dann zusammen mit markus söder am
flughafen in münchen entgegen genommen
hat endlich mal gute schlagzeilen
ministerpräsident hat mich gebeten
auftrag erteilt 5 millionen masken
allein nach bayern geliefert jetzt
beginnt wirklich die luftbrücke richtig
also fassen wir noch mal zusammen dass
andreas scheuer noch im amt ist hat vor
allem drei gründe es liegt an einem
untersuchungsausschuss der zwar alles
fragen kann aber wahrscheinlich niemals
alles rauskriegen wird
an markus söder und auch ein bisschen an
krone und mich würde ja sehr
interessieren was ihr für den
entscheidenden grund haltet also macht
doch gerne bei unserer kleinen umfrage
mit ansonsten freue ich mich über eure
kommentare am besten gleich viel direkt
unter dem video und lasst uns auch gerne
gleich wissen was euch sonst noch so
interessiert an der berliner politik wir
korrespondenten beantworten eure fragen
und wenn euch diese folge gefallen hat
dann abonniere doch unseren kanal und
jetzt könnt ihr gleich weiter schauen
hier gibt es noch eine spannende
recherchen von frontal 21 über scheuer
und das wort desaster